let's go next to uh let's go to travis
from manila is this manila in the
philippines
yes sir can you hear me yes i can are
you uh you an expat
yeah i'm just here for work okay
uh my question for you and thank you for
taking my call big fan pleasure um
considering and forgive me i i don't
have the poll in front of me but i just
seen a poll that said something like 80
percent of americans were just
completely done
with any
or all coveted restrictions yeah would
it be wise politically for democrats to
move
in that direction
yes and i think that basically they
already are i mean i think the biden
white house hasn't yet really put out
anything
specific about like we're going to the
next phase here but i think many states
are thinking in that direction even like
i heard from family in in massachusetts
that
the school guidelines and you know it's
a republican governor in massachusetts
but it's you know liberal legislature
they're going in the direction of
normalizing a lot of school stuff um i
think i don't think the risk is over to
any degree
um but i don't know i don't think so
either but to be clear politically makes
sense yeah i you don't think it makes
sense to get rid of guidelines or you
don't think it makes sense to keep them
i don't make i i don't think it makes
sense to keep them right yeah no i'm
increasingly of that mindset and part of
it is
with cases going down so rapidly
and the belief that we're moving into
the endemic phase endemic doesn't mean
mild necessary necessarily you can have
something that's endemic and serious
it's just a question of like we were
talking about with vincent raqueniello
two weeks ago what milestone are we
waiting for in terms of
omicron is we're well beyond the peak
and
um
masking and vaccines
are
widely available everybody sort of knows
at this point the level of risk that you
have i it's a question of like what's
the next milestone we're waiting for if
we don't start easing off of stuff now
and making things more kind of personal
decisions
what do you think the answer to that
question is
i i mean i think it's
if there is another
variant that makes cases spike and it's
not significantly milder like if the
next variant truly is just a cold then i
think we don't do anything but if
there's a new variant that is just as
dangerous as the ones that we've had
you probably put some guidelines back on
as my sense
okay i i appreciate the time david thank
you very much my pleasure thank you so
much for the call
one of our sponsors is splendid spoon
now if you're like me i love planning my
meals out for the week but sometimes i
just run out of time to plan them for
every single day and splendid spoon
makes that whole process a lot easier
they deliver fresh delicious plant-based
meals right to your door ready to eat no
cooking no cleaning dishes saves you a
lot of time you can choose from over 50
hot and cold meal options there's
smoothies grain and noodle bowls soups
i'm a big soup guy many of you know that
i also really liked the vegan meatballs
with marinara noodles delicious
both eye and splendid spoon believe
eating more plant-based is a great tool
for feeling good
for helping the environment the list
goes on i'm not vegan you all know that
i think but splendid spoon is really
great to just help me maximize the
proportion of plants in my diet splendid
spoon takes all of the work out of tasty
healthy plant-based meals and you'll
save 35 dollars when you go to
splendidspoon.com
pacman the link is down below